every day of our lives we live in a
world that is incredibly complex and you
have to remember we all have a
two-million-year-old brain and it's not
designed to make you happy it's designed
to make you survive so it's always
looking for what's wrong so why would we
allow this to be because it's just a bad
habit and so we need a daily practice
and so I want to show you how I do this
for me and I want you to create your own
system based on it this mind serves me I
don't negotiate with it remember I told
you I don't say well I'll do this well
maybe we can do it maybe I'll jump in
the water now it's like it knows I'm not
here to negotiate when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
they do that whenever you want to make a
change or improve something the first
place you want to prove it is in your
mental emotional state if you do
something from a pissed off state from
an exhausted state from a frustrated
state from a weak state you won't matter
what you do the thoughts are weak when
you're in a weak place the actions are
weak so the first thing we're going to
do is I'm going to show you a simple
breathing pattern and the breathing
pattern if you're familiar with yoga
it's like Breath of Fire it's similar to
breath the fire and it's a movement is
what's gonna look like is this you're
gonna sit up in your chair with energy
we're gonna raise your hands up as we
take the air in and then you're gonna
blow it up
oh you're gonna blow it out your nose
and we're gonna do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're gonna do
this with your eyes closed then you're
gonna drop your hands down palms up on
your weight on your legs and you're just
gonna feel whatever you feel you might
notice some tingling you might notice a
sense of peace you might just feel
relaxed and then we'll do another 3 sets
of 10 another 30 we'll relax and then
another so what are three sets of 30 3
sets of 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 - 10 with a
break between them when you're done with
that you're ready to prime because it
puts you in state priming is three
options it's done in 10 minutes you can
do more than 10 and many of you will
enjoy it so much you'll go longer but
the reason I do 10 minutes of priming is
I wanted to come up with a daily
discipline there was no excuse not to do
if you don't have 10-15 minutes for your
life you don't have a life so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do our 3 sets of
10 3 sets of 10 3 sets of 10
our eyes closed the first three and a
third minutes of the ten minutes is
we're gonna focus on three experiences
in our life that we can feel deeply
grateful for three of them and we're not
going to think I'm like oh this this
this we're gonna take them one at a time
spend about a minute each and step into
that moment in your life that you could
feel grateful for it could be a little
thing or a big thing it doesn't matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it like to be
on a roller coaster and you remember
timing you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there you're going to give me a
very different feedback then if I get
you to imagine the moment you were going
over the edge and you're in the front
seat
then you're gonna show me a different
result you want your gratitude to be in
the front seat not an intellectual
gratitude out there so I take three
minutes a minute each I come up with
something different every time I think
of a moment that I could feel so
grateful for a blessed moment a
beautiful moment a loving moment a
sacred moment and I step in and feel it
and flood myself with a gratitude
gratitude is the antidote to the two
emotions that mess up most people's
lives
what are they anger and what fear those
are two Biggie's
you cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and prime
yourself for gratitude
the more you can push through anger and
fear very quickly and by the way when I
do it I usually pick two strong ones and
then I pick something really simple and
I make myself really feel the gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is if all you do is
get grateful about big things you're
gonna miss most of life after we do our
breathing step one of the three steps
first the breathing then the three steps
one gratitude three minutes roughly a
minute each three different moments you
can feel grateful for and feel it enjoy
it
savor it live in it next three in the
third minutes second piece we're going
to do is you're going to feel the energy
in you and
you a prayer or a blessing now I know
many of you are not religious I'm not
suggesting you need to be but almost all
of us know there's a power in love you
know
if God was love and we didn't come up
with all the other names for God you
wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is imagine energy of God the
universe whatever you want imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down the end through
your body down your legs into the earth
and then coming back up and out again so
it's and it comes back up and you have
to do this with your hands but I'm
trying to show you what the feeling is
and while you're doing this what are you
gonna do during those 3 minutes is
you're gonna give thanks it's like a
prayer saying heal my body my mind my
emotions strengthen me make me the best
I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the 3 minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
half I then take that energy through me
and I send it in a circle around to my
children to my family to my friends to
my co-workers to my associates to my
partners to the people I meet on the
street to my clients and so it's taking
the energy and now you might sound like
Lulu's stuff but the idea of allowing
your nervous system to heal and
strengthen just the focus of that alone
for you as strong and sending to others
as well so you can think it's all both
but try it and decide based on the
experience if you do in a while I think
you're gonna find
it'll a deep in that sense of gratitude
because it becomes not only gratitude
but healing or strengthening and a gift
of those you love the last three minutes
I call three to thrive you're gonna
think of three things that you really
want to accomplish or achieve but
instead of like hoping it happens or
thinking about it happening you're gonna
step in your mind and experience it as
if it's done you're gonna see it or feel
it breathe it celebrate it like you've
already achieved the goal what you're
doing is training your reticular
activating system and we talked about
this the other day the part of your
brain that notices things when you did
you know before you bought that car
outfit you never noticed them now you
buy the crowd
cars and outfits are everywhere how come
because your Ras now that you own one
says this is important I need to pay
attention to this well when you get
clear what you want and you see this
done and feel it and create it in your
mind and your heart and you celebrate it
there's a sense of certainty than
there's your body and your reticular
activating system starts to go to work
on making it happen so you spent a
minute each one of those so basically
three minutes each 3/3 minutes each and
we're done if you want to do the actual
exercise with Tony guiding you along
check the link right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there there we
go
[Music]